and here to tell us more about the state
of malaria research is an expert in the
field from the Max Planck Institute for
infection biology kai ma two chefs key
thanks for joining us here on tomorrow
today now isn't that really risky to use
a living malaria parasite for
vaccination I mean who take the risk
well I would certainly take the risk
because I know about the impact of
malaria every live vaccine is a risk and
we have to be prepared to take that risk
now in tubing and you're in very good
hands it's it's a very good clinic you
were supervised 24-7 throughout the
clinical trial and and so that would
work there's no risk for the volunteers
of this vaccine trial and yeah the
approach then is actually not feasible
for Africa not as it is now so to
transfer this to Africa is long way to
go you cannot simply imagine to take
this vaccine on a muppet to a small
village in start vaccinating young
children but this is a way forward to
develop a whole attenuated parasite
vaccine what could you actually learn
from a trial like this well what we
still don't understand is the signatures
as we call it the signs of protective
immunity what is it actually that we
recognized in order to mount an immune
response that we don't see in the field
and and so to disentangle the small
antigens the immune cells that provide
this unprecedented level of protection
is really what all the researchers would
like to understand and so the advantage
of using a whole parasite would be that
there are lots of different approaches
the parasite services shows lots of
different faces for the Indians festival
arabia's because we don't know what the
protective antigens are we have to leave
it to every individual to recognize
whatever they have as a protective
antigen mm-hmm now we've heard in the
report that there is another vaccine
called RT SS that has received the stamp
of approval from Europe's medicine
watchdogs what do you think of that it's
a first step and it's a very important
step it's the first malaria back
seen ever it does a fairly okay job in
preventing clinical disease so a third
of the kids are having fewer episodes
but it doesn't do well at all for the
severe malaria for the implications and
the mortality of malaria so we are we
are nowhere near to having this as a
tool to stop malaria mortality and it's
an important step forward but currently
it acts like a bed mat I would say I
understand so as long as we don't have
any vaccinations of course we need good
medicine artemisinin is kind of getting
weaker are there any new substances in
the pipeline well not really they're
very early in the pipeline there are a
couple of good candidates people now
engaged more to identify these new
medicines and compounds but we sort of
lost time and now with the threat of
tolerance against artemisinin we really
have to speed up to develop new
antimalarials how in point is that fight
against to to win that fight against
malaria it's one of the major challenges
medical challenges in this century it's
one of the top three killers together
with HIV and TB and it's it's something
we have to address as a community thanks
a lot for the talk ki-mata cesky